John I started the Punisher it's a good
show top 10 TV villains had justifiable
motives that's the video we're gonna
watch today whoo top of wart here a
patreon whatever video that is requested
let's say a reaction or a discussion
about something we must definitely do it
put up on the youtubes or create a
feature film that's the new request
today is from Andrew Hayes it's a
watchmojo.com video top ten villains who
had justifiable motives TV villains
specifically god I hope that guy from
the Gili I forget their name not the
White Walkers the [ __ ] oh yeah
so be sure to subscribe to our channel
and read them out to get notified better
well tell you that the end of this
oh yeah Mardi Gras Chevy Chase it's just
an episode community who offered to host
children for each person
I've seen an episode or two kate
beckinsale the age-old question Falls
for good but that's a good question
make sense
Al Bundy was I'm not starting the show
now number six the wildling
she's great from complex 15 Jaime
Lannister and theon greyjoy
to entire civilizations like the
wildlings for most of the inhabitants in
Westeros the wildlings are definitely
the bad guys fight with Barbary it's not
fit to live in civilized wins but while
they may have done some pretty terrible
things they're hardly unique in that
regard and in the series timeline
they're really only trying to get you
across the wall so they can survive the
impending zombie apocalypse stay I think
called zombies
like my one freaking show that I like
any crook
in history eventually costs him to go
down a dark path but one from which he'd
eventually find Redemption seeing the
complicated journey of Rumple over the
course of the show has shown us how deep
his character really is oh yeah but he
betrayed his family I don't think
well that explains odd mr. krabs been
loved since the krabby patty recipe
while plankton is left to his own
struggling lost yeah I don't remember
his motive it was eventually revealed
that the monster was no mortal man who
was escaped it was implied would cause
the end of the world we didn't find out
his history until nearly the end of the
series and to be honest the episode
didn't do a great job of making clear
exactly what it was that made the island
so important
sure is that the man in black was raised
by a woman who murdered his mother and
you just wanted to leave the island
number one he's even better and better
well he's committed some terrible acts
he also plans to leave all of his money
to his granddaughter we often visits and
clearly cares for deeply it's really
very sweet the characters mix of
violence and crime with noble motives
and it reluctance to hurt anybody who
didn't have it coming
earns him the top spot on our list don't
make me beat you to your legs don't work
tell me where to find him you know
what's the right thing
[Music]
it's funny watching him looks so much
younger here but in the pre city looks
so much older in the prequel that's
before I got the work done in the
context of the show yeah I hope him and
Jimmy both get plastics that's how I
want a little five years younger well
this was a good list I've seen all day
I've seen all these shows I can comment
on each one of them what's the
governor's motive in like actually get
the motives of a lot of these people in
the walking dead
yeah the governor I mean what happened
to him I mean he lost his family and
he's like grieving over that and so he's
trying to build this idyllic community
for everybody yeah but he's also making
these messed up experiments I mean I
guess I think he wants to reverse his
daughter to write something like yeah
yeah that's a good motive the key to
making any anti hero or villain likable
just give them a family but give them a
sick or or ailing family so it's really
that simple guys yeah the best trope or
if you're doing a movie they want to
cleanse the world for the crazy good
yeah humanity is really running amok
here and so it's things right again we
just gotta wipe it all out yeah just go
wipe it all out man I know what makes a
good villain I didn't really feel like
they went into the motives of a lot of
people a lot of them were just kind of
explaining why we like yeah yeah I love
in penny dreadful Frankenstein's monster
he wants to have a wife you know what's
a bride to be creative for him have you
seen the show I've seen what I saw over
your shoulder oh man and the guy plays
Frankenstein's monsters so good like his
motives every time he starts speaking
like yeah you're scary but I'm totally
on your side every single I create
you're like this crazy like violin dude
at the same time like I totally gay I
feel like you make Frankenstein look
messed up whenever I hear your motives
Frankenstein's always fast I feel like I
guess they didn't include him here
because Frankenstein's monster and Frank
sign has already been done in the movies
and stuff that episode of Sherlock has
always kind of stood out to me I
remember when I first saw the first
episode yeah and yeah no I mean that was
like the first impression I think that
that show had a chance to leave on me
it's another one of those guy with the
family I don't know like it's it's
interesting because I do think that this
list kind of fudges the line between
motive and just what makes a sympathetic
character how really like Mike's a
villain I wonder that at the time I mean
like there are times when he's at odds
with Walt and Jesse but he doesn't seem
like the villain no you know especially
the way he ends up - he works for the
villains but he also works for Walter
sometimes you know yeah he kind of seems
to work for whoever is in line with his
moral compass and who has the money yeah
Tim it's like saying punisher of
daredevil season 2 is like yeah when i'm
like yeah he's portrayed like that in
the first half that he's the villain of
the season with a very justifiable
moterz if anything I feel like that
earns a spot on this list more even Mike
whatever Breaking Bad yeah because at
least there is that period of that
season where you're like oh yeah this
dude's definitely a bad guy yeah he's
not trying to kill daredevil but you
know chains up people and tries to push
daredevil the murder and yeah you know
he's a very violent guy in that season
so I feel like you would be there I'm
just gonna punish her Punisher hi right
now aren't I yeah totally just on a
Punisher hi that first episode man yeah
did a number on you
Tyrone Magnus could be on here he's
every reactors villain and he's got such
a relatable motives cuz you gotta keep
keep that channel rolling keep making
that ad money you know and back to
daredevil I don't know if Wilson
disqualifies in this list after the
events of season 3 but in season 1 I
thought he had great motivation
justifiable motives for why he really I
was really sold he wanted to make a city
a better place yeah that's part of
what's so cool about that season is that
he and daredevil essentially the same
motivation yeah the wildly different
approaches to it and that made for a
very interesting season - TV
you make a list like this and have zero
honorable mentions I imagine it's met
with a lot of controversy a lot of
backlash as you can tell 2.4 k likes a
hundred thirteen dislike oh man
so clearly this video has audiences
split a lot of people agree Anala people
agree no that's for sure these are the
worst villains the worst of the worst I
really took like a lot of them were just
oh that's why I feel sorry for them you
didn't really dive into their motivation
for why they want to be villains yeah
yes I'm like not motivation why they
want to becomes a motivation for their
purpose and drive for what they're doing
that ultimately lands them in the
villainous position yeah it's it's the
kind of thing where it's almost you need
to kill monger type where you're like oh
that philosophy makes a lot of sense not
like a Kevin window.chrome type where
you're like oh yeah you've been
traumatized that's really sad but you
also do terrible things
I feel like this happens a lot we watch
these lists is we're like is this really
exactly on top of you know I feel like
the motive of man in black and west
world was a more proper motivation than
a lot of these you know it was pretty
fascinating like once you find out it is
like weirdly fascinating even if it
doesn't make you go like well I get
where he's coming like you do but you
don't get on board with him and kilgrave
I was thinking about that he does not
have just about motives although they do
a great job you understand you
understand how that works out and they
do a great job with his manipulations
for a hot second in that season where
you're like oh maybe he wants to reform
himself you know like maybe he wants me
come on the Frank Grimes one though
first of all I'm like yeah that's a good
call that's a good call that's a totally
thinking outside the box who's gonna I
think of Frank Grimes you know and I
love those kinds of things to or like a
small character yeah that kind of
significance in a show but I'm like
that's perfectly justifiable motives
hell even Sideshow Bob has better mo
hates the made Bart specifically do ya
for your guys favorite TV villains do
you agree with this list oh I got a good
one I mean it's kind of a spoiler Oh
where you are in the show or show Buffy
the Vampire Slayer what season 5 or 6
angel alright guys well Andrew Hayes
thanks so much for recommending this
video I don't know what your obsession
is of watchmojo.com buddy I mean we'll
keep watching them for you
mojo we'll keep talking about them for
you you keep supporting us so we'll do
our part I just don't know why I feel
like he likes the idea and sometimes
he'll be like yeah people disagreed with
this or watching always happy for this
video but you know maybe some variety
man what about a looper or or Screen
Rant well I gotta tell ya I gotta tell
you Andrew Hayes is working on something
pretty big right now what's he working
on if I'm not mistaken if I pull up this
new message John I want you to react to
this mess ok well two goals that I have
her that I want to be more consistent
with making videos and I mean a few
friends are gonna be making a movie so I
would love for that to be released this
year hot diggity man what kind of movie
everybody's doing I will be producing
writing acting and directing and
composing the music and he has Lady Gaga
in it he's doing so much with this movie
good luck you're going this adventure
you're gonna be tired this is the start
of your M night Shyamalan journey for
this a very afternoon I discovered that
he wrote directed produced and starred
in his very first film good yeah good he
wants all the attention so does Angier
hey we're all those has where them all
it's not gonna stress you out one bit
yeah joy being tense on set but in all
seriousness that's that's awesome
it's brave of you best of luck on your
adventures buddy all right well
subscribe click that notification bell
shaggers up a three on the bed